stop the show Gang get an important
announcement the boys are doing a live
stream New Year's Day come hang out with
the squad down here with Toadies we're
gonna have some special guests might be
an appearance from Patty and Denise you
don't know what's gonna happen it's
gonna be a good time get a hair and a
dog in you kick off 2023 right and that
ain't it you bozos we got a third show
at the Gramercy theater shout out to the
army of garbage baby we're on sale now
our third show it's going to be February
3rd that's a Friday night get your
tickies now New York City Army of
garbage let's go welcome to another
exciting edition of are you garbage the
show where you find out if your favorite
comedians are classy individuals or
absolute trash now here are your hosts
Kevin Ryan and H Foley hey everybody out
there and welcome back to everybody's
favorite new podcast this is are you
garbage jingle jingle jingle it's that
little show we sit down with your
favorite comedians and we find out they
give it to be clichy yeah if you're just
a big old piece of trash trash trash I'm
your host Dave trolley coming at you on
a beautiful day it's the Christmas
Spectacular uh-huh we're down here at
antuti's basement she's upstairs passed
out under the Christmas tree okay
nothing says the holidays like a
middle-aged woman knocked out on store
brand eggnog sure laying under the tree
my co-host is coming at you from across
the table looks like you should be
working at a piano bar later sing us a
song big headed man gang he is the CEO
of Ru garbage's International
businessman he's my Santa Claus he's the
gift that keeps on giving a whole year
long give it up for KJ Kevin James Ryan
hey what's up gang thanks for tuning in
this jacket is a little snug left over
from last year remind me I put the
pounds on there
Sam ain't the only one bulking up huh
you know what I mean it's cuffing season
thanks for everybody for tuning in as
always just make sure you rate if you
subscribe on iTunes full video available
on YouTube as you know those numbers are
through the chimney some would say okay
uh and then obviously the greatest
goddamn website of all time
www.patreon.com you sign up you get
bonus episodes you get episodes ayg you
get [ __ ] Vlog content you get all the
bonus videos we've done it's a whole lot
of [ __ ] and also I want to mention the
third show over there at the goddamn
Gramercy theater tickets for that baby
that's gonna [ __ ] go that's gonna
sell out as well three sold out shows
let's [ __ ] do it gang yeah I love it
don't forget about that live stream live
stream baby January 1st a little bit of
hair the dog The Hangover show live from
Toadies we're coming at you at moment.co
slash ayg sign up get tickets baby the
fun things going on this house we're
doing it we do a lot of stuff around
here and having a nice quick shout out
to our producer Rick short and air the
magic man makes us all look good works
the ones and twos crosses the t's dots
to the eyes make sure Santa Claus gets
home safe every Christmas Eve give it up
for T-Bone McMuffin Toby McMullen what's
up dudes what's up T-Bone I threw my
back out I'm dying man I hope you didn't
throw your back out buying a sound bars
again
probably carrying that big hog around
with all the time get a reduction will
you Jesus Christ there's no shame in it
your stripping days are over
you threw your back out oh yeah man
welcome to it baby oh God it's awful and
you can't even take nothing good to ease
the pain no will you take Advil or
Tylenol or anything like that I was
thinking about that I never do really no
I don't know why I never take pills huh
never take pills never go to the doctor
nothing's wrong with me at all sure I'm
the same way deny it denied than I I
love pills and go to the doctor
and I'm not unhealthiest one at all is
gang welcome to the Christmas
Spectacular uh-huh we're here
Extravaganza if you will spectacular
Extravaganza patent pending yes holiday
Extravaganza holiday you want to be very
inclusive to everybody whatever you're
doing whether you're going to heaven or
hell if I can start throwing holy water
at somebody
but gang we're here we can't thank you
enough for an amazing year it's been a
fun year been a great year thank you to
[ __ ] everybody thank you to the team
the squad the army of bozos we [ __ ]
love yous couldn't be more grateful good
time what is on the uh docket for
Christmas for a young fellow like you
this year well as you know I'm very
Multicultural I celebrated Hanukkah the
other day the first day of Hanukkah
really yeah I had the menorah we
FaceTime [ __ ] FaceTime the in-laws
cause the birds uh Jewish ooh yeah you
know that yeah I would have loved to
watch you do that prayer like a guy at a
concert who doesn't know all the lyrics
oh I just checked out I was yelling at
the dog most of the time
I was waiting for someone to come pick
my chair up
that's just a wedding let's go
uh yeah it was a good time yeah did it
over we did it I was at my mom's for our
family Christmas party like the big
extended family Christmas party right
and we had to do uh the first day
Hanukkah was in the morning so we did
about 10 o'clock and Denise was there
good Catholic lady now just to pull the
curtain back a little bit we were down
there interviewing the birds last week
the birds are gonna be on the live
stream if you haven't seen the picks if
you haven't heard the hubbub uh we
interviewed Denise and Patty for the
live stream and I got to witness you
pitch this Hanukkah celebration to
Denise in real time sure yeah uh-huh she
took a belt off a bottle of Evan
Williams I don't know what that tells
you oh [ __ ] sorry bless her so yeah I
know there was a couple more crucifix
laying around the house that morning let
me tell you I didn't know I didn't know
how she was going to act I don't ask for
a trade now buddy we're about to win the
Super Bowl she stayed at she sat in on
the thing because she knows my in-laws
from the wedding and everything uh so
and they email back the moms do they
communicate back and forth so she sat in
and she loved it she's busy she's a big
religious lady you know so she's like oh
you guys are celebrating it's it I'm in
and if you just don't mind I'd like to
end in the Lord's Prayer
bless us oh lord for these I give
it's like a goddamn holy war in there
it's like the cold war the Russians and
the Americans are trying to turn each
other I know it's a good time it was it
was great it was a very joyous
celebration thank you any Hanukkah gifts
no uh no from who I don't know no ain't
crazy nights I don't know you get
presents nah they just do they're uh
they just do the first night as like a
big dinner or whatever and then like
dreidel did I yeah no chocolate little
chocolates a little the little coin
chocolates gelt I love those things gelt
that sounds like a fish first time first
first time I saw that felt a fish and
they told me there was chocolate in
there I didn't believe them and man when
I opened that thing up sure as [ __ ] if
there's chocolate in a three mile radius
you're gonna sniff her out
I don't care how many stones Jesus
turned this guy's giving away chocolate
baby
puppy sign me up for the squad let's go
yeah I was out here chewing on silver
dollars
ah I think they're all chocolate
buddy that's a washer the [ __ ] that's a
20. what are you doing
that's how they get you try to throw me
off
Ah that's good stuff it was good stuff
and then uh Christmas Eve I got planned
at my sister's house that party has
moved to my sister's house nice from
from Denise's to my sisters
um she's gonna cook and that's a good
time over there it's trashy we've gotten
into those Tick Tock games Tick Tock the
kids like playing The Tick Tock games
it's like uh the first time so they have
like a big counter similar like my Mom's
Kitchen like the big like yeah
and you take always a sign of a rich kid
ladies and gentlemen in the 80s and 90s
sure when they had when they had the
island it's went back that's what that's
that's back when it Ryan's had a couple
of bucks rolling around I used to look
under those look at those islands and be
like man yeah must be nice sure and then
your family breaks up and it's not that
nice
for one Christmas all right
everything gets cracked up to be
how about one loving family how about
that
yeah that's pretty good
um
what would I say oh so they do uh the
one year we played I think both years we
played it you taped like dollar bills
down like a boat like it's kind of like
bowling and you roll up we I mean we
were rolling like a beer I know what
you're talking I'm trying to get the
stop on the money to win a couple of
bucks yeah that and then we did another
one where it was like you Saran wrap a
bunch of toys and presents and like a
big ball and it goes it's like a dice
game it's like 7-Eleven doubles a little
bit you got a [ __ ] yeah me and my
family are doing a case race
Beer Pong Champion
playing beer pong with martinis yeah
getting all [ __ ] up
everybody was throwing olives
holy
holy
um the birds family does that kind of
stuff I didn't know it came from Tick
Tock I swear it got big yeah they do
something with the cotton balls and
everybody's around they got they're fun
it's a good time and you realize how
because then me and my brother get real
competitive we you know it's like sure
start ruining it yeah exactly the reason
why you didn't do it growing up oh of
course yeah the reason we weren't
allowed to do it because we ruined so
many surfaces or whatever yeah we never
did anything like that like as a family
like that like games as a family
yeah guys are watching football drinking
we never did the now it's a but now it's
like you know
family versus family sure sure I was
always I got Hans bite my nephew you get
him get him she spits
we won again and Tebow what are your
plans
I'm going down to North Carolina visit
with the fam you don't say you can pack
your overalls what are you doing
get them dry cleaned yet Yeehaw
Hillbillies I think I'm finally gonna
have the gumption to hit on my cousin
there you go what's his name nothing
[Music]
alignment for the county uh I'm not
quick today I'm playing hurt nice guy
all right
we got new guy Luke sitting next to him
in case he drops out
ready to pick up the microphone and bomb
start talking into the headphones
kid's a little gunshot on camera
good stuff yeah what are you doing I'm
heading down we're heading down there to
Blue back I'm heading down not to somber
to move but first year without the big
man this year
um heading down there Christmas Eve
morning scream at my mom a little bit
straighten that dumb [ __ ] out
man I saw it you guys are something else
that's where I get it from I know that's
like the [ __ ] yeah yeah that's like
the uh you know that's the that's the
Fountain of Youth of crazy right there
that's where it all comes from yeah
because what'd she say she said
something we said we had something good
coming up and well I can't remember what
it was the first thing was are you gonna
get in trouble for that oh yeah can you
get sued for that I mean it's all doom
and gloom with those old broads so you
guys you guys were setting up uh to for
the interview for the live stream
available January 1st you can buy your
tickets now
um and I was out back having a Bernie
with her in a Bernie Hut sure and uh the
Bernie hunt and the Bernie hunt try the
buffet
um and she uh
I know she's uh you know the old broads
they like to Doom and Gloom you know
people passing away of course
whatever so I started giving her some
she was eating oh yeah yeah where are
they who's the doctor yeah what hospital
they in how did they not all they wanted
how didn't they catch it until then it's
all that cause she was sure she was
eating it up yeah I was like crazy
that's the first time I've ever seen
someone bum a cig off someone's mom
she had more blights I go hey can I have
another one she could charge me a dollar
if you ever want to see my mom light up
man when she sees that Life Alert or
that life helicopter uh coming in to
scoop somebody up and they're probably
going to harlemen
Jesus Christ so now she likes a nice
Coast Guard Chopper coming in just to
save a family out that there's water
skiing
ah but no so we're heading down there
and we'll stay down there we do my
cousins Christmas Eve that's a real nice
party sure real good time uh a bunch of
little you know picking at things and
this and that [ __ ] got the birds that
night yeah
holy big Showdown Dallas Texas so I'll
be watching the birds over there and
then I think we are gonna reignite a
Foley family Christmas tradition
headlocks what are we talking here go to
the ER
trip to the ER concussions
um we're gonna do Midnight Mass
wow Maddie wants to do midnight mass
midnight mass when she gets off work
I'll be there at 1205.
midnight mass and we did a one I'm I'm
off the mass I'm off the mask sure I'm
off in I've been off it for about eight
years now uh I go weddings and funerals
that's it that or you know Kristen and
your kid or something it's the only way
to get me in a church
um or a hell of a bake sale we'll do it
too I gotta be honest man shout out to
those Bundt Cakes God damn dude I
remember having a lemon square for the
first time [ __ ] blew my doors off
Jesus never look back right it's been
all green light since homemade baked
goods really are something I tell you
good time you also have a knack for
talking uh
uh to anybody about any type of food a
dish a food group sure an ingredient
anything sure you and my mom the other
day talked about pineapple stuffing for
about 14 minutes which is pretty much
just pineapple and white bread and you
guys you guys were able to talk for 15
minutes about yeah use the can what are
you doing you put it in a 350 yeah yeah
she's a good time man it was fun we were
also talking about Honey Baked Ham how
big they hit in the 90s sure every she's
like there's one right down the street
there we used to go all day Honey Baked
Ham over here in Newtown Pennsylvania oh
wait a little coating on the outside
crispy and delicious now we used to do
back in the day this is before we moved
down to Bluebell when we were up in uh
in Wilkes-Barre which seemed like the
50s to be honest with you when I look
back on it it was the or it was
beginning of the 80s but it might as
well like it was in black and white sure
it was old school yeah yeah we'd go to
my small town small town we go to my
aunt Mary Catherine uh on Christmas Eve
it would just be like her and my and my
uncle my uncle red and they'd have like
presents for me and Andy he'd have like
a little train set up under the
Christmas tree go in there it'd be real
dark and like just like you know lit
like you know just a tree lit up it was
beautiful it was fantastic we'd do that
and then we go back to the house fight a
little bit do whatever and then we would
get all gussied up get in the shower do
all that [ __ ] get my tubby get some suit
that she picked out or whatever the [ __ ]
and we'd head over to uh St Mary's and
do midnight mass yeah and then come back
and it'll be a fresh pair of pajamas
waiting for me we're gonna meet up in
the middle of the night
so you can put in my jam James to get in
my plastic sheets it'd be a fresh pair
of fresh new pair of pajamas waiting
there always [ __ ] shout out to Patty
waiting for us on our bed but I found
out years later she did it for for a
little bit of a selfish reason reason
she wanted to make sure that we looked
somewhat presentable that morning for
pictures sure that makes sense because
we weren't allowed to come down you
crossed that threshold dude my dad would
have like Claymore set up when you hit
the bottom of that staircase you had to
wait because they had to take pictures
of you when you came down
it was a good time
um you're looking sharp now in your
Christmas shirt thanks pal I can't wait
to see it in fact he was just wearing
that that's not even that's not even a
Christmas shirt that's all the it's the
only thing that fits and that was clean
he's got a job interview after this
this will come out in early 2023. I'll
tell you that it's the holiday season
[ __ ]
till late March it's really the holidays
and told Valentine's Day
no no no no I just got my tree that's a
hundred bucks I'm leaving that [ __ ] up
for [ __ ] Saint Patty's Day I'll tell
you that yeah I don't even think we're
doing a tree I might look at this little
guy I was running around are you Jewish
what do you mean doing a tree
hey let's go can you do that thing will
you kick the legs out the Russian dance
yeah man dude I went to it I told you I
went to a Jewish wedding man and I had
to do it right God damn that place was
jumping yeah that's [ __ ] fantastic
but no we'll do that we'll do Christmas
day over at my brothers uh give the two
little brats their gifts
um sounds like you're in the [ __ ]
Christmas spirit get a couple of uh pork
roll egg and cheeses thrown at me on the
hamburger rolls that's how my brother
does it yeah yeah and then head over to
my cousin Kelly's for Christmas day with
the whole family which and I've told
them this before in private it's my
favorite
four hours of the Year okay they got a
sweet place the basketball games are on
everyone's running around it's all
catered and nice and chilling out and
hanging out a couple of cocktails Big
Comfy Couch couple of big dogs man good
times we do that Christmas day uh we go
to my aunt Kate shout out to my aunt
Kate uh classy clay braw died okay don't
I
think I met her redheaded broad
moving over to her place when we were
down at the big guys no I was saying
Patty damn Patty's on Patty and Uncle
John okay uh no uh she's real classy a
couple of bucks
got a real nice place and you go and it
feels like you're having Christmas on
like in like a rich move you know what I
mean like it feels like Kevin McAllister
like the furniture is real nice
everybody's dressed up because we feel
you know what I mean like everybody's no
one's wearing jeans make a reservation
everybody puts a pair of Docker new pair
of Dockers everybody's got the new
sweater on it still has the crease you
catch a cousin with a tag on it's going
going to this says extra large on the on
like the arm or whatever going to the
relative's house I had a little bit of
cash was always the best that's a good
time you go and you just feel nice and
we are right I feel like you're showing
you like you're gonna buy it yeah
how do schools over here
is water included or what are we doing
here
um and then we all drink Manhattans me
my me and my uncle's probably about five
six years ago started drinking
Manhattans they were and I never touched
the stuff but then I had with two
treated M would you like them now I'll
tell you that man in a nice fancy glass
glass all right you feel you feel like a
million bucks you feel like a real rich
guy take down Manhattan's like your
Dutch huh you know what I mean history
folks look it up okay let's talk about
rock and money baby uh who don't love
money who don't love Rockets rocket
money who don't love saving money you
know a lot of people don't know what's
that big conspiracy on the American
public and worldwide for that matter of
course A lot of people are signing up
for subscriptions they don't even know
about and they forgot about it forget
about it a lot of people think it's
about 80 bucks a month it's more like
200 2 million two million so do yourself
a favor get over to Rocket money and
make sure that the subscriptions you
signed up to you want to be signed up to
and the ones you don't cut them loose
yeah you might even find out you're
being double charged it's easy peasy the
app shows you to all your subscriptions
in one place and cancels whatever ones
you don't want to cancel a subscription
it's easy peasy just hit the cancel and
Rocket money takes care of the rest they
got the muscle they got your back they
sent a couple of goons over knocking on
knocking on someone's door oh hey take
my boy off the list you don't want Hulu
no more guys get rid of get rid of
useless subscriptions with rocket money
now go to rocketmoney.com garbage
seriously it could save you hundreds a
year and who don't need a couple hundred
clams walking around pocket money with
rocketmoney.com today patent pending on
that that's right your unnecessary
subscriptions right now and put a little
pocket money with rocketmoney.com today
do it yeah Kip just put your box baby uh
we'll put your box Best In The Biz
butcher back the best in the biz holiday
season makes me think back to when I was
a young little fat kid we'd break out
the seafood for New Year's New Year's
Day yeah be nice have some nice
delicious steaks on the table for now
holiday season you know where to get
good top Quality Meat your grocery store
no what are you an idiot butcher box
grass-fed grass-finished wild caught
free range the whole nine yards gang do
yourself a favor get over to butcher box
and sign the [ __ ] up uh yeah go just
what you want delivered right to your
doorstep free shipping for the
continental US no surprise fees you can
choose from a variety of box plans sure
from curated to customize change the
plan whenever you want uh I let them do
it I like them you know what they're
doing I know what people like they take
care of you takes the guesswork out of
it uh they got recipe inspiration guides
tips hacks and some are even
personalized so you can cook up mouth
watering males exclusive member deals so
you can stay big on your favorite Cuts
this holiday season is made better and
tastier with butcher box for a limited
time they're offering our listeners
ground beef for life that's crazy plus
you get 10 off your first order so I
don't have anything to run over there to
give away all this ground beef sign up
today at butcherbox.com
ayg use code ayg to get 10 off your
first box and ground beef for the life
of your membership that's butcherbox.com
eyg use code ayg to claim this deal
today do it uh but let's get into what
let's get into the [ __ ] the the
turkey here yeah let's [ __ ] do it do
some prezis ooh Some Prezi
if mistakes have never been higher if
you haven't tuned in last year it was an
absolute debacle quick rundown Toby got
us Toby got me and Foley sound bars for
a TV sucked police fully hooked his up
his didn't work I gave mine to my cousin
to put it in short I don't know how but
somehow mine made the move man it's in
the noop it's in the new apartment you
believe that [ __ ] oh man yeah not for
long trash days tomorrow that thing's
going I'd give this that thing's going
back to the Jungle the number of fist
bumps and quiet sound bar is a great
gift that I've gotten before live shows
dude yeah from other nerds I presume a
bunch of virgins out there got me laid
what are you doing and then I got Toby
concert tickets and they already had
tickets for and then we weren't even in
town for the show uh you got him what'd
you do just eat those a Game Boy uh yeah
I guess we just said you didn't resell
them no I gave them to the homies oh
there you go uh we'll take our cut
did you wet your beak and then you got
him a Game Boy I Got This prick a
[ __ ] Nintendo switch that he already
had and lied for eight months and then
finally came out it was like hey man I
had one the whole time I brought it home
played it once I haven't I don't even
know where it is you bought me a base
that's behind me I have I don't think
I've ever actually touched the thing no
I don't think I've ever picked it up
without once there's an amp over there
if you want to slide into DMS I'll give
you a real good price
I think this year is going to be a
little bit different I think so too uh
and then what did I got oh we gave
T-Bone we gave T-Bone a Jihad list cash
money yeah
you're well compensated enough
[Laughter]
just got off the phone with my account
for a couple bucks back I I pronounce
Santa Claus Sam yam shout out to Sammy
and Jack the real elves that's what I
call them should we do let's do looky
patooki first all right Lukey patooki's
over here Lukey slide in Bud hop in the
middle seat there jump in here big guy
yeah yeah
oh God new guy looking here on a public
episode look at that ladies and
gentlemen a little eye candy for the
ladies hold the Applause there he is New
Guy Luke
get some color will you get out of here
at this kid alive will you from Philly
you're [ __ ] scurvy over here
thank you
man this guy Perfect all right not the
sharpest one I thought he's I'll tell
you that much so for you for everybody
knows no guy look this is new guy Luke
hired this year we love you to death
buddy uh out on the road together he's
The Mastermind behind the Vlogs and the
um
the the bonus content uh editing and all
that stuff that's correct all right
um
nice kid good kid young kid lives down
in the Lower East Side tripping the
Lights Fantastic uh off to Connecticut
after this spend time with the fan yeah
shout out to the fam so we got you a
couple of gifts here
number one t-shirt
middle class famous I look good on you
this I got you an extra medium by the
way thank God I already stole me and
then what I was here he was selling them
at the Boston show he probably we got
you not one but two kamikoto knives
only already cut himself on by the way
one of them has holy blood on it
hey I don't touch that during a full
moon
where's the medical waste basket then we
got here Aura whoa picture frame look at
that whoa that'll go they're great
presents to give I hear what else you
got over there bottle of water
room temperature just how you like it
unopened that's nice this totally wasn't
last minute Luke and then we got you the
last pack of the ayg playing cards you
can play with the family
and then I got one more thing here
a Rhode Island comedy connection school
bag there you go that's Oakley by the
way and I think there's a mug in there
yeah there's something in there shout
out to the comedy connection baby and
also a thousand
that's totally not prop money either
spend that anywhere it's Martha
Washington
that's right Lucy you'll be riding to
the style in the Northeast Corridor on
your way back to Connecticut wow
you could not have come at a better time
you just gotta raise nothing this kid
Jesus I'm spending left and right
obviously this stuff was a joke
we're gonna need that for contractual
purposes oh this shirt's coming back
with me though it's a small
gonna need an armored vehicle look thank
you for everything buddy we appreciate
it don't forget your water that's for
you at your parting gift cards you can
keep I think maybe not the post office
jammed us up and lost like 100 orders
but they're coming folks
don't be silly you probably got them
already buddy
Merry Christmas Merry Christmas we love
you happy New Year happy holidays great
job this year okay oh and he's got his
shoes on and he got it suplex down in
Philly shout out to Mikey from suplex
shout out to suplex in Philly
um now I'm not going to Connecticut uh
okay you lying little thief you're
moving in oh you brought got presents I
got some friends whoa thank you to Mr
and Mrs Dempsey
and that Amex gold card you guys got
that the big dog has up there shout out
to Kippy just got the raise that's where
the thousand dollars coming in okay all
right let's go let's see whoa this was
very unexpected because we just invited
you like two hours I know unless it's
stuff you found in your apartment when
were you gonna give this okay you got my
NutriBullet
look at this all right whoa this is
pretty good heavy bike coming in
Lukey
for Kippy first every single
entertainment entertainment Mogul needs
a fresh pair of these okay
better be assless chaps just saying
oh well broken cardboard box just what I
wanted Luke
this is all baseball trophies in there
oh [ __ ] oh crispy ones daddy look at you
guys put your sunglasses on these things
are is there a bag of fentanyl from
there too to go with it I always wanted
fake hair forces this is great shout out
to Canal Street thank you very much Luke
thank you man that's awesome coach you
have a hanker for some soup dumplings
down here
hahaha
now fully yes
your gift has not come yet I love that
just like your girlfriend
first gift I ordered November 30th okay
damn you got ahead of this speaking of
the money I really did I really did I
tried to okay okay here's a placement
holder present hat is it one of yours
yeah
it's got a sweat stain in it now you're
cool fat guy Foley exactly very nice
we're gonna put you it's gonna be a new
hat in a hopefully a week or two okay
but no worries okay
is it this brand it is that brand who is
it Stevenson Ranch okay sweet shout out
to Mike but you're the size of a cow
Foley loves Ranch
more of a Hidden Valley man to be honest
is very sweet of course I love you guys
thank you buddy and then T-Bone I got
you this T-Bone come over and open it up
here you go T-Bone our T-Bone's back
hurts oh yeah is it a muscle relaxer by
any chance do I need it
all right
stay spicy also you did not wrap any of
the gifts I got invited last minute it's
like a hot ones [ __ ] hot sauce I
think one's missing now that looks like
for four no that's five three okay nice
awesome new guy Luke coming in correct
slap it up for new guy loose thank you
brother found some stuff in his
apartment
a half a bottle of Franks
you get Franks you get Franks I don't
know what I'm gonna do with your remote
control thank you
with bad a batteries
very sweet thank you very much for
everything changed my life of course
love you guys thank you buddy love you
man thank you all right changed my life
I asked how you told me that on the road
the other day I was like change your
life he's like yeah lateral move
the funniest thing Luke has ever said is
when he looked at you and you were
wearing shorts it was freezing cold he
goes do you feel cold like normal people
yeah it was all right man I think about
that every once in a while just start
giggling
shout out to new guy Lucas without the
NGO can I give you guys your [ __ ] sure
sure and then we'll do T-Bone and then
me and the big man wait no you give us
your you give us our presents we'll
throw them out and then we'll go do you
want my cousin's address
man this thing's gonna stink man he's a
medium
who's that for
my bow or something
what are we doing I mean dude the fact
that you didn't even okay the big one's
mine all right okay here you go uh all
right get that thing out of here this
one's hissing I don't know what's going
on
okay wait it's blocking all of the shots
all right so these gifts are for
somebody got into the cocoa early huh
they're both for both of you they're
both for both sharing them yes but I
feel like these might be like cameras or
something he wants for the studio and
just saying he bought them for us a new
gaming chair
it doesn't matter which open is open
first guess what you wanted a sweater
with my cat on it
okay
I love doing that
all right
I kept it traditional just straight
Amazon no no wrapping
condoms
oh walkie-talkies
on the road dude nice with earpieces so
that we can do we can be like CIA guys
there that's very sweet that's very nice
yeah we've been talking about it forever
we have we've been talking about we
always want to walkie-talkies on the
road where are you at meet me in the
lobby red team go I love it that's great
okay I'm gonna
off camera a little bit yeah I can I can
uh I can turn the camera
all right kippy's over there opening up
to present
breaking out his keys
like to see it okay
a lot of stuffing in there
yikes there's a dead cat in there I'm
gonna be upset
[Laughter]
all right you down there what the [ __ ]
was it an engagement ring
hey there we go
it's pretty good
not bad some top quality cookware for
the fellas how are we gonna share that
there's there's one for you one for
Gippy and one for Luke nice oh that's
sweet
very nice
that's great
that's great that's all right that's
beautiful
very nice there we go look at that so
that you guys can slam dunk in the
kitchen
that's pretty good that goes into
recyclables by the way just so you know
Kip what'd you say I said that goes in
the recycle
let's go right into Facebook group
OBO real quick as is uh T-Bone that was
beautiful thank you very much that's
great so nice of you my wife will be
thrilled yeah they're top quality I'm
telling you all right until you've been
why don't you come over here and sit
down and we'll do uh we'll do yours
all right
I forgot to get T-Bone something you did
no Jesus my mom's gonna be pissed
she actually likes walkie-talkies
would you hand me that the red one
please buddy so there's a card and then
there's something in there open this
open what's in there first okay you guys
got me I don't know my cans yeah yeah we
got it all right hard first no no open
the open the the thing first all right
bet get on the mic a little more just so
I know that it's uh yeah yeah
all right we got here oh an islander's
hat yeah a team I've never seen a game
for
now open the card oh [ __ ] and read it
out loud okay
and then get out
and get in the kitchen Christmas
hope you like the Hat because you're
gonna need it when you and one of your
Dirtbag buddies are sitting Center rice
at the Islanders
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah I think take on the
number one team in the NHL the Dallas
Stars uh I had the bird write this out
so the writing looked nice
so funny yeah Toby thinking of you and
wishing you uh a Christmas filled with
joy we love you dude thank you so much
your eight rows back off the ice out
there in uh in uh Belmont or whatever
it's called wherever the wherever the
UBS arena is they're playing
they're playing the Stars 7 30 game
January 10th which isn't that far away
great you got anything uh Yes actually
what I've seasoned tickets to the
islands
I meant to tell you guys and and we'll
take we'll get you an Uber out there and
back thank you guys so much thank you
you want a friend I got two tickets I'll
send them you can put them in your
wallet [ __ ] yeah dudes yeah oh thank you
boys of course [ __ ] yeah enjoy it Merry
Christmas guys Merry Merry Christmas we
love you this one seems to be better
than Legends this is doing all right
this is all right okay this is doing all
right do you want to go first you want
me to go first uh you go first I give to
you yes you give to me uh-oh
wrapped by Me by the way Toby hit me
dude I noticed that earlier it gets
crazy wrapped by me bought the wrapping
paper this morning did you have to watch
a YouTube tutorial on rapping no I'm
pretty good it's like the whole process
is messy but I can get you pretty
decently a lot of tape and places there
shouldn't be tape but I get you decent
looking that's a decent looking finished
product mine would look nothing like
that
all right here we go I'm opening it up
shimachi what is this
what a Prestige like a card too
oh it's taped on the side okay
we're a prestige
Prestige authentic item confirm
some of the most quality control
okay
can't tell what it is
what the [ __ ] is this dildo kid
what the [ __ ] this is fine leather very
fine leather very expensive fine leather
what is this
whoa It's a cigar uh I didn't feel them
because I wasn't sure exactly sure your
brand that's [ __ ] nice but it's got
the cutter it's got the lighter it's got
the little holder there imported from
the UK dude it's very beautiful white
and crafted leather and on top of that I
also that's like a holder you like put
it down look I didn't want to make it
public but yeah I got into cigars a
little bit you got in a cigar by
accident so now you don't look like a
bozo when you go to Club mcanuto up
there on the Upper East Side dinner for
two what oh yeah ah get out of here dude
all of these gifts are like prices right
prices I got you two sets of kamikoto
knives ah this is sweet uh reservations
uh and everything's all taken care of
you and whoever okay uh at Club mcnoodle
on the Upper East Side I talked to Mr
Paul verzi says nice is one of the
nicest ones in the city
this is beautiful thank you very much
yeah you can't smell it yeah that's it
it's all right I might strip this thing
there's a little make a pair of shoes
out of it
also too I wanted uh so it's a very
upscale place okay no sneakers it's a
cigar bar but they serve food yeah it's
like a very good restaurant okay well
Club social club or whatever uh and you
have to wear dress shoes and a collared
shirt okay which I also bought you but
they didn't show up in time
apparently it takes longer to make a 5x
button up than I expected dude that's so
beautiful yeah
um yeah so that's that's uh hopefully
you'll enjoy what's the card uh this is
actually from uh my wife what yes
all right
very nice a couple of nudes
okay I got a little racy photographs it
just says payments are due on the first
you still owe me Four G's you fat
bastard
this is beautiful
too Foley from Nadine
don't make me come looking for you next
time
I swear to God I won't
I'm looking at box didn't spray acid in
my face teach me a lesson buddy that is
so sweet thank you about thank you
hopefully you enjoy it and also I
wouldn't mind 100 at the club mcanoodle
by the way I'm going to a hockey game
with you thank you yeah me too you're
not going I'll tell you
ah this is fun the dinner drink menu at
that club mcanuto is all right yo you
heard what Kippy got fully for Christmas
he's going to Club macaroni he's going
to the Macaroni Grill
that is dude that is so sweet I love
that because I even said when we were at
home uh just real quick I had a cigar at
uh Cassidy's wedding sure I hated it
verbally like outwardly hated the idea
of it you complained the whole time hey
did he complain the whole next day I
hated it yeah hate the cigars the whole
nine yards the whole thing and then the
next day it just kind of got in my head
a little bit where I didn't really hate
it as much as I thought sure which is
everything with you we were supposed to
go to the uh the Phillies game the World
Series the night it got rained down on
Halloween we ended up at another place
sure chicken sandwich fair enough uh
probably chicken sandwich and uh and I
had one there I had a Macanudo there and
it was [ __ ] awesome I loved it just
sitting there relaxed and I was all
[ __ ] up on shrooms but still it was
the topless broads running around and
then when I went home a few weeks later
I was like you know what I'm gonna
[ __ ] I found a cigar shop I went and
got a couple of mac and noodles I had
one on my mom's deck and I liked it and
I've had a couple of my mom's that I
wanted that I wanted to smoke and I even
said I wonder if they're gonna get uh if
they're gonna get bad I got this
beautiful case to keep them in I love it
thanks buddy I love you thank you
brother also you're going to club
mcanoodle with a friend
we'll go together
Paulie
[Laughter]
get the car clean baby we're going for a
ride
new guy look what you hand me that
so Kippy this is from me
for you okay all right uh just undo that
and
yeah look inside
what else would I do just uh open it up
and take a look and then say thanks
needs to be fed immediately
it's a little bow yeah just give that a
pull I got it that's it nope you can
tighten it relax oh you're not making it
shut up you're not making it any better
smells kind of weird
I'm just being honest it's got a bit of
a stench would you give me cheese or
something
that's good Roquefort there you piece of
[ __ ]
that's fresh gouda you got
ah good stuff all right oh my God
a nice fedora
there you go what and there's one more
there's there's there's there's one more
thing there better be tickets to Cuba
there's one more thing in there
okay okay all right maybe it is tickets
and there's one more thing in the bottom
there okay open that up okay
okay because you're gonna need that hat
because Kippy
this is making me real nervous dude I
feel like Vin Diesel
man you look so ridiculous I feel
ridiculous but you're gonna need it I
don't I don't want to open this man open
it up what's it say
pack your bags you're going to the
Bahamas yeah
yeah
I got you a cruise baby
[Laughter]
that's right KIPP Arena why I'm sitting
in the Poor House you and your number
one European gal they're gonna be
cruising through the Caribbean
[Music]
what what you're already going
you bought the cruise line
guy with a hat like this of course I'm
gonna Cruise Line
or at least a set of Bongos man thank
you very much you said you wanted to go
on a cruise sure well you're going oh
yeah
and I didn't Peggy in on a date that
right there that was gonna be my excuse
not to go
you gotta be kidding me I'm kidding
thank you very much I didn't pay you
down on a date what you have there will
cover any three-day cruise from here to
Delaware
any three-day cruise room balcony Ocean
View Whole Nine Yards
or equal or lesser value
you go anywhere you want or apply that
however you want it but they do a
three-day cruise out of Miami to the
Bahamas there's one in October okay okay
October October okay
your reservations next week what do you
mean October
October 2028 you can go away for three
days oh thanks man I appreciate that
been working my goddamn ball sack off
he's got the package on layaway so
that's what the final payment goes
through I'm gonna show them like there
you are finally I know you said you guys
might get away so I didn't want to Peg
you anything I appreciate that is the
gift receipt in here or let's go
be kidding me
that's a thousand dollar gift
certificate I could probably get 250 for
it there you go no thank you very much I
appreciate that is that something you
think you'll use
uh who are the sponsors this week we'll
be right back after these commercial
breaks gang this episode is brought to
you by better help let's say remember
this what's that life doesn't come with
an owner's manual it does not a lot of
people are a lot of screw balls out
there not all sunshine and rainbows now
if you knew what I was thinking right
now you'd run for the hills he just said
he was in the depths of Hell ladies and
gentlemen I swear to God gang if you got
something going on you want to talk to
somebody about it do yourself a favor
get over to betterhelp reach out to them
by locking in with a certified therapist
that can help you work through whatever
you're working through yeah guys I've
been a big uh big proponent of uh talk
therapy it's fantastic it did it's like
uh the release valve a little bit just
let someone steam out of your brain let
somebody [ __ ] uh
hear what they're talking [ __ ] about me
is that what you're doing yeah for sure
of course I say my best friend's the
craziest person I ever met and he
refuses to go to therapy and I say hey
use therapies betterhelp.com there you
go uh it's the world's largest therapy
service better help has matched three
million people with professionally
licensed and vetted therapists available
100 online plus it's affordable just
fill out a brief questionnaired a match
with a therapist if things aren't
clicking you can easily switch to a new
therapist anytime it couldn't be simpler
there's no waiting rooms no traffic no
endless searching for the right
therapist uh learn more and save 10 off
your first month at betterhelp.com
garbage that's betterhelp heop.com
garbage not back to that goddamn show
back to the show uh yeah probably yeah
of course very nice that's uh that's
great I had a feeling it was something
when I saw that yeah if I just gave you
the Hat that's great
take the cigars back
[Laughter]
you can hand me quality [ __ ] we're
talking about now do we want to do any
uh what's it called uh white elephant or
anything do you want to switch it up
oh [ __ ] that I got I got 500 on the
Islanders for sure
because I promised my girl would go on a
cruise
give me your hat I'll treat you straight
up
Ah that's great thank you very much I
appreciate it thank you Merry Christmas
Merry Christmas all you guys thank you
very much Merry Christmas
and the homies we [ __ ] love you thank
you for [ __ ] everything
um
and we do have uh typical ayg fashion
you know what I mean sure I posted over
there on a patreon hit us out with your
Christmas themed stories questions
we're also doing our hard feelings after
this so we are doing I really want to
find out what we thought of the
president Sure tune in this weekend
um
all right let's [ __ ] let's get into
that I'll also just to put a button that
was way better than last year sure I
believe I believe everybody's relatively
happy with 100 at least we're saying are
you yeah are you yes I don't know what
do you guys think you think he's happy
he doesn't know how to express Joy sure
true it's not on Luke
Luke raise your right hand if you think
he's happy
he raised his left
oh he went right you said you wanted to
go on a cruise yeah thank you thank you
you're taking you're taking this
personally I said thank you very much
I'm gonna go on the cruise with me what
it's just me and yeah it's for you and
the bird too by the way yeah I saw I
think you just got one ticket I saw it
printed out on your home computer thanks
for that
you ran out of ink halfway through the
picture by the way but they didn't have
any retail establishments in the city
thank you plus it goes to Hedonism too
hey pick me up on the way back will you
Carnival
I'm gonna hang out here for two three
days they're ripping in the tearing
um all right
good merry Christmas everybody yeah I
hope everybody has a nice uh time with
their families of course nine yards
um
but let's get into uh a couple of
questions here this is the ones from Ian
Finance or fine ass shout out to Ian
Finance love it uh is it garbage if your
Christmas stockings growing up used to
be your mother's pantyhose I mean we
could see everything that was in there
that's a tough look
yeah you could that's what paid for your
presence
yeah that's a tough one pair of fishnets
uh were you big stocking people huge the
stocking always had
the really typically a hand
towards a really good gift you find a
pack of batteries in your stock and you
know they were you know you know you got
some [ __ ] free you know some fresh
tech gear coming in uh also too because
they would always be like due to
stockings if people run a typical run of
the scenario was presents then stockings
yeah for us sometimes wait presents then
stockings yeah we did stockings first
presents the fake out of that's
everything and then the big gift pulled
out from behind the couch that was
similar yeah I'm gonna fight uh
depending on uh what the psych out fake
gift whatever was outside whatever you
know was uh there was typically a hint
in the sure in the thing you know what I
mean of like uh the the batteries or
whatever accessory type thing some
bullets what some bullets
um well yeah I mean that's also part of
the fun was yours was your stuff
individually wrapped in there where in
the stocking we would have a little bit
yeah yeah if it was like a box or
whatever like it would be individually
wrapped truth be told Patty hooked it up
yeah also that's where the scratchers
went oh we were a big scratcher fast
we're still to this day uh my stepdad
will come in Christmas Day and break us
off like
40 bucks each or something like that
there you go but then always the thing
if you got to split it with me sure
which uh gentleman's rules sure
the thing about the the best thing about
the stocking was the
anticipate was like you can't see if you
could see everything in there you're
just like oh there's a [ __ ] sack of
batteries hanging it and don't those
pantyhose aren't they connected aren't
pantyhose connected to the other gifts
to the other flag
no you can get individual stockings
really like they wear like the ski masks
like the you know when you're robbing a
bank or something no the ones I wore
always had the second leg oh yeah what
were you getting into
um the birds still wear those stocking's
still a thing yeah yeah really yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's trash cold weather in a
dress throwing a stockings all right
good to know
you were talking about Christmas fights
you know it was an all-time Christmas
gift when we hit the scene late 90s
sock'em Boppers you guys ever get those
no but we my buddy did and we used to
hit each other to the where like the
it had the
seam
around it and if you hit someone dude
the scene would [ __ ] it would leave a
well on your face what's they were blow
up [ __ ] boxing gloves oh really like
just big like [ __ ] they were like
this big and you put your hand in there
you just sort of [ __ ] rock each other
really get a Christmas Day Fight Club
going with all your cousins yeah we had
the thing that was like heavy on the
bottom and you would hit it and it would
come back punching bag yeah they were
that was a good time oh I used to [ __ ]
that thing I'm making out with it
um those were good but yeah the Rockets
the the rod not rocking soccer robots
was that or no yes that's a game in the
little soccer
Rock'em sock'em robots Rock'em sock'em
that was 70 [ __ ] still they were still
banging when I was a kid really yeah
yeah the commercial the head would pop
up that's all you wanted
um
yeah any anything like that we weren't
allowed to take over to the bigger party
because it was like you're not you're
you're just gonna turn up you're gonna
do a fight yeah you're gonna break it or
you're gonna sure but you want to show
off the new gear something you know yeah
hey look at what I got you know you
sound like a loser like hey I got that
uh I got I got the new N64 at home like
yeah whatever you do I'm sure you did
kick rocks I got yeah I got a pony too I
was always allowed to bring a GI Joe or
something with me I think always a car
ride there yeah yeah you know for sure
new fresh pair of jeans probably a new
sweater everything fresh socks on these
some [ __ ] that didn't fit and itch the
[ __ ] out of me [ __ ] brutal could have
been more more GI Joes
yeah goddamn proxy war on our hands um
all right this one's from Ross Reed you
get a scratch off this is what we were
just talking about you get a scratch off
ticket as a gift and you hit for 100k do
you break the person off who gave you
the ticket with a little bit of cash or
tell them to kick rocks that's life in
the big city
never gonna make it in Show Business
Escape
I would split it
split yeah it's split Christmas who's
giving it to my cousin or my mom
splitting it's no there's if it was my
mom the whole thing would be in her name
of course yeah yeah kill her
um
splitting it's crazy I know right
splitting it's crazy think I think
what's gentlemen's rule
if I it should be stated ahead of time I
want ten percent that's what a real true
dirt bag does sure get out ahead of it
hey verbal agreement you know legally
binding I want 10 of that
I think I think if you hit for 20 if you
hit for 100 I think 20 is fair no you
got to throw him a little cash something
I but I it's coming into holidays we're
in the holiday season get out in front
of that people you don't want to [ __ ]
hit for you know 40K and then someone
coming to what their beak heavy-handed I
mean I don't think you should say this
but 20 would be the
gentlemen's move sure I will give you 20
so if you win 100K you give them you
throw that's why the 20s all right 50.
that's all after taxes and stuff like
that
you're not getting 20 off the Jump
figure if you do 100 G's you're walking
out of there with what 60 65 probably so
then you give 20 so you got 40. it's
pretty good for scratching
that ain't bad
I don't know I want it all you said you
had to pay taxes anyway
[Laughter]
I
feel like Vin Diesel
um all right let's see this was from
Justin is it garbage to save I mean
we've heard saving [ __ ] wrapping
paper but this is is it garbage to save
all the tissue paper from present so
your mom can iron it and reuse it next
year holy [ __ ] that's gotta be a fire
hazard yeah
it's like 13 cents I know I use that
liberally when you're stuffing oh I
stuff I'm always I'm always the guy I
showed to my moms we're going over my
sisters or my aunts or wherever and I'm
like I didn't do any rapping I go I'll
talk today so you got bags she goes yeah
but I never have bags that fit my gift
right I always got like a huge bag for
like a little piece of whatever and I
gotta put a hundred either you can't oh
I got like a couch pillow in there I'm
trying to [ __ ] fill that thing I
dropped that off at Patty's Workshop
what do you mean wrap this up let's go
get that [ __ ] wrapped up but when those
bags started coming around and start
again she's still wrapping your presents
she'll do a couple this year I think
yeah and it's gonna wrap a couple okay
one or two for the kids when was the
last time you wrapped you wrapped a
present do you think ever
ever gonna start no
no no why would I why would I need to
start wrapping presents when you're
working the North Pole I don't know one
of the birds will do that they do it
better if you give the job to the person
who does it the best
all right laundry
no
coconuts no I'm the fat piece of [ __ ]
also also by the way this just in we got
the recipe for the chicken cutlets it's
gonna be on the live stream and strap
the [ __ ] in will ya
I mean there's one or two three four
steps in there where my me and Toby made
eye contact like what the [ __ ] why
they're so good
they sure have Mountain Dew on hand
ladies and gentlemen
there's a good crystal meth yeah keep
them coming back a little bit
um yeah that's I mean we my stepdad
would save the wrapping paper from time
to time I've said before though we just
throw it right we used to if we have the
fire going at my mom's we just [ __ ]
launch it right in there that's fun just
[ __ ] torched but then you know living
room gets filled with black smoke a
little bit too much you know what I mean
when he throws in up he's an army guy or
something show up to your cousins
looking like a bunch of coal miners
faces all blacked oh helmets on
oh stuff yeah that's a that's a wonky
one uh this one's for Matt ten dollar
long time shareholder is a garbage
should not have celebrated Christmas
until you were nine I had a Matt's first
Christmas sword and at nine years old
holy [ __ ]
I mean I get religion
no like I assume just [ __ ]
dirtbaggery yikes he ain't gonna
remember it anyway yeah but at Nine's a
little different I mean like nine yeah
three maybe four I mean I don't remember
Christmases from three or four
I do also but if you're looking back and
you're like it's not crazy if you're
like oh the first Christmas I remember I
was six you know what I mean
yeah you see what I'm saying yeah I got
it which I get but it's like God damn
what do you telling a kid nine huh
should send him something hey you want
to go to the Bahamas
see if he needs a couple of
walkie-talkies
and one of Luke's old hats yeah
um uh all right let's see here this is
from Ariana M my garbage family
Christmas tradition is that my mom would
make us think Santa's reindeer puked on
our front step the puke was oatmeal she
would make in the middle of the night
and dump it outside then wake us up in
the morning to show us the reindeer puke
she would only do this every other year
because apparently it's too weird if we
had a pukey front step every year
that's a good time right there that's
all right that's what I've never heard
of I've heard of the reindeer poop it
was like it's like raisins or something
chocolate chocolate raisin something
like that the big thing now is the
[ __ ] Santa's Boot Steps through like
the powdered sugar or whatever to make
it look like snow oh that's pretty good
that's not bad I've seen that online uh
listen as much as I love Christmas and I
love Santa Claus like I said when we do
the midnight mass and we would get home
that would start a six hour
wheel of anxiety and panic that it took
me until I was like 12 or 13 to shake I
was petrified of this guy coming into my
house even at 12 I don't know why I do I
would lay there in bed with my eyes open
all night Jesus
staring at my door just waiting to see
like this huge man just peek in
just waiting for him I don't know why
for some reason I thought he would be
he would hurt me at night but but
there's no stories of that leave me
presents in the morning is that why you
gained all the weight why don't be a
fair fight
so I was a 400 pound 12 year old all
right here's the rule we split six
cookies
no chocolate gentlemen's rules yeah
petrified the Easter Bunny forget it
dude you can still you can still see a
bad Easter Bunny nowadays like the The
Mask or the helmet on it get the [ __ ]
out of it where it's like they look evil
they got bloodshot eyes and big [ __ ]
sharp teeth they're like buddy try a cup
of deacons and I never knew if the
Easter Bunny was like self-aware if he
could like talk or if he was just like a
wild animal
just a rabbit
see the hall light just waiting to see
somebody peeking and one or two years I
think my dad like threw on the hat in
the in the in the hair and I like you
know just to like make sure that we were
asleep oh man that was a long one Jesus
Christ like [ __ ] sitting in a foxhole
all night just waiting for a bullet
somebody get this guy in ativan's that
Jesus Christ pretend in the morning it
was great until next year I wouldn't
have liked a reindeer puke
uh yeah I actually feed them
[Laughter]
it's also like get I mean clearly sick
get someone else you know what I mean
you don't want to get the 13th reindeer
to step in for the game what's the
health plan up there let's go
um all right this one let's do uh two
more here and then we gotta skedaddle uh
this one's from Sean first time ten
dollar Bozo we all know it's trash to
skiing jeans how do we feel about
snowboarding and sweatpants
[Music]
sweatpants hold snow in a crazy certain
way where you just look at it and you go
that guy's poor yeah right away you look
at it you're like buddy go hold the
you're behind on some sort of payment I
get it as a kid I used to love wearing
sweatpants inside out because they felt
really good and I went out those in the
snow they come out like a Yeti almost
like a llama
holy [ __ ] really sticks to you oh man it
just bowls up on you I would do it
sometimes it drags them down too oh yeah
they get real heavy dude you're
retaining water weight
um I remember one time it was like it
snowed for like a long time and you know
like the longer the snow days go the
less gear you have because like oh that
that's wet that's worn out sure so it
was like and I went out in sweatpants
like we built like a little snowboard
jump on this like little Hill in our
neighborhood and we had like these like
toy snowboards they were like plastic
and we were like riding them and I
remember those I was in [ __ ]
sweatpants and I mean
right like I knew leaving the house I'm
like I'm gonna I just you know I was
lying to myself it's like when you leave
the house and the socks already fallen
like around the heel and you're like
you're like it'll be all right I hate
that dude I made it like two runs my
little Dinger was [ __ ] inside my my
nuts were turning to little acorns it
was bad I went right to my legs I
couldn't feel my legs for like two weeks
all jammed up did you ever do the
plastic bags tied around the shoes of
course of course with rubber bands we
would know so we would do
plastic bags in the
all around the sock that in the shoe so
your actual feet wouldn't get wet
plastic bags and sledding on a cardboard
box the H Foley story never went
anywhere you had bigger problems and
Santa Claus coming again
[ __ ] worried about an imaginary guy
in the Easter Bunny meanwhile sledding
in a frying pan I know what the fahisha
curry frying pan that is oh God damn
right is it is that Santa Claus no it's
the Repo Man
that's why you were afraid they were
telling you had the [ __ ] bill
collectors or Santa Claus
I didn't know Santa Claus took our
entertainment center
must need to go back to the North Pole
to get fixing uh
um uh this one's from aider tits off uh
uh basing what you give for Christmas on
what your your holiday bonus from work
was
that's all I was yeah up until last year
it was whatever I got
I knew I was gonna get [ __ ]
broken off with those Amex gift cards
most of my boss most restaurant jobs I
got like 100 or 200 bucks I think yeah
that was that paycheck Before Christmas
is is Christmas is Christmas yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's I think that goes for
for everybody of course dude I remember
being like hardwood for my dad I could
spend like 30 heat like each part like
the six people I had to buy for whatever
I'm like each one is like try to keep
around 30. sure if I splurge a little on
her on him or her mom always get mom
always got what like I'm like out here
you know I made you this or whatever you
know what I mean she always got the
short end of this thing yeah she wrapped
it 34 doing macaroni yard
it says your name
says Denise says Dennis you spell it
wrong
all right we gotta wrap it up gang well
hang on though okay we gotta do the uh
oh right I apologize plus the Night
Before Christmas a little uh a little
are you garbage tradition here we did it
last year toady's rendition of twas
Night Before Christmas sure
um again shout out to all the homies all
the bozos love you baby for a great year
we love you to death looking forward to
a great 2023. thank you to you guys
obviously as well so let's see here got
it in the phone and if you're looking
for a present check out tickets for The
Gramercy theater
don't want to miss it very meant the
Islanders I thought you meant the
Bahamas
I can't wait for his hard feelings find
out what the real T is all right here we
go uh-huh
Twas the night before 30.
as read by H Foley okay it was the night
before Christmas and all through tudy's
Place The Joint was jumping the music
was pumping it could hear it from space
Tony's crew were getting together to
spread a little Christmas cheer but we
knew there'd be trouble later when they
ran out of beer
me and the fellows were chilling up in
our room just minding our Biz T-Bone was
working on the computer Kippy three
Manhattans deep Luke was taking a whiz I
just hooked up my CPAP and was ready to
snooze when I felt hot breath on my
cheek which reeked of heaters and booze
and Toody's face was an inch from my
head she said that fat piece of [ __ ] is
up on my roof with those reindeer and
sled I said what's with the insults he
got beef with Old Saint Nick she said he
ghosted me last Christmas after I sucked
on his whoa whoa whoa
I said why the hell are you telling me
this she said because I want you four
idiots to help me steal his sleigh and
really put his panties in a Twist now I
knew stealing Santa's whip would damn us
all to hell but when we got there oh boy
what a story We Tell Kippy and T-Bone
came up with the plan we'll steal his
keys then lock him in the can
as the Clock Struck midnight we made for
the roof
but first rubbed our balls on the
cookies just as a goof
hahaha
Duty took a round of the shoulder as
Santa went for his gun
yeah things elevated quickly I thought
we were done
but by some miracle of God we made it to
the sleigh all safe and all sound Kippy
slammed on the gas to get us off the
ground and as we climbed through the sky
we heard the old man shout I'll get you
punks if it's the last thing I do the
Geezer cried out but we were long gone
out for a little Christmas Cruise
probably stopped by Sev grab Bernie's a
lighter Cheez-Its and booze what a
perfect way to end an amazing year in
this holiday season stealing Santa
Claus's ride for no goddamn reason
Tootie was smiling from ear unto ear she
whispered to me fully I think this is
gonna be our year and I heard her
exclaim as we drove out of sight sign up
for the live stream it's New Year's Day
night
and shout out to all the homies and all
the bozos for making everything all
right and a Merry Christmas to all and
to all a good night